we need a full investigation into the
FBI would that be something that you
would support yes but I think I have
gained enough of an understanding of the
FBI such that I can confidently say the
correct answer is not to give them some
new building or anything else it is not
to replace Christopher Ray which is just
a which is just a fake Mirage get
Christopher Ray out you get James Comey
2.0 I'm convinced the right answer is to
shut down the failed Bureau of
Investigation the FBI that's the only
answer that remains and I actually think
you guys are
you know playing almost nicer with
respect to the facts that we do have as
I said you know I agree that it appears
to be an inside job but we don't really
know the full extent of what happened I
will say though it's interesting I don't
know if you guys have talked about this
in the show before I've kind of gone
deep on this because I think it's
important not just for this incident but
for the future of the country you know
who the Detroit field office head was at
the time of the alleged Gretchen Whitmer
kidnapping plot are you guys is
something you've talked about before or
not really
yeah this is this is important though to
understand the Nexus it's kind of an
underbelly in our law enforcement so the
Gretchen Whitmer kidnapping plot
actually began as a plot to storm the
capital in the state of Michigan and you
know how started it started was people
at the FBI putting people up to this
poor guys one of them was actually
supposedly getting hot water from a
Mexican restaurant across the street
these are people who are not doing well
in their life who they've put up and
cultivated with $5,000 credit cards with
$5,000 limits to go by Munitions and
otherwise to initially what began as a
plot to storm the capital but eventually
ended up being a plot to kidnap Gretchen
Whitmer a good number of the people who
were captured here like we're talking
about a high proportion of them were
absolutely Federal informant and yet the
Detroit field office head and they took
that all the way to trial several of the
people at trial were con were acquitted
on grounds of entrapment one of the
jurors at the end went to one of the
defendants just gave him a hug and
apologized for what he had been through
cuz the juror actually had to see what
the FBI put these people up to and you
can't make this stuff up in October of
2020 3 months before January of
2021 guess who gets a promotion to be
the DC field office head was none other
than that Detroit field office head and
what do you have on January 6 2021 3
months later is a storming of the US
capital so there's a lot here that
suggests I mean the DC pipe bomb story
at the DNC and the RNC headquarters why
haven't we heard the first thing about
what we actually know despite the
existence of video footage about that
and the ful Coincidence of exactly when
that pipe bomb at the RNC headquarters
happened to have been discovered with
the timer on it down to the time where
the actual vote was supposed to be cast
for certifying the results of the
election it's it's just an impossibility
that was the number one thing for me I
mean yeah the day after and sorry to cut
you off but the day after January 6th I
was like this is it's complete set up by
the FBI I mean if you mean to tell me
that I was living in Washington DC at
the time a couple of blocks away from
the White House when January 6th
happened it was very bizarre day because
we had an entire summer of people
rioting it was scary to go outside I was
pregnant at the time uh cars set on fire
every day there was a a crazy protest
people storming buildings at all times
suddenly after the Summer of Love BLM we
were getting phone calls people asking
if we were okay after January 6 when
there wasn't any any sounds outside of
where I lived if you mean to tell me
that in Washington DC where you can't
walk 2 feet it is the most surveilled
building in the world okay that a couple
of blocks away from the White House they
can't figure out where there again
cameras on every single Corner every
inch who got out of their car placed
pipe bombs that the RNC and the DNC
headquarters and went away and let me
tell you how extensive their church was
this is something that people are not
talking about because you you're talking
about people that stood trial and of
course that's the most important people
that are being locked up people that
have committed suicide let's not forget
to talk about people that have killed
themselves for fear of being locked up
because they showed up to support the
sitting president of the United States I
have two friends from Stanford
Connecticut who showed up to hear Donald
Trump speak and went home okay that was
it they never went into the capital
building nothing after the speech they
didn't go up FBI agents showed up at
their house this was a harassment and
intimidation campaign that took place if
you even showed up to support president
Trump they got questioned they got
questioned they were they found a
picture of them on Facebook with a Maga
flag they heard Trump speak and they
went home and these people were
questioned by the feds so they had
enough resources right to send them out
and down people that were posting
pictures but they can't find out who
just tried to blow up headquarters in
Washington DC a couple of blocks away
from the White House and you want to
know what the weirdest part about this
is and I'm just as I go deeper learning
facts about this is kamla Harris the
number two for better worse to to
succeed the US president was at the DNC
headquarters that
morning with all I mean the level of
security there that understand then
suddenly they randomly they just see it
in a park bench later so so I think
there's enough facts here to know the
government has not been transparent with
us but furthermore we know Capital
police officer let him in we know that
the video footage was success was
selectively released such that you did
not see shooting rubber bullets and tear
gas into the mostly peaceful crowd you
saw the reaction of those people hitting
Capital after releasing that and then
you did not see initially Capital police
officers allowing peaceful in people in
peacefully it's a distortion and we just
deserve the truth well I have I have a
question for you so I've I've often
talked about the May 29th Insurrection
May 29th 2020 thousands of far-left
extremists stormed the barricades of the
White House fought with hundreds if not
uh several hundred police officers
injuring around between 70 and 140 they
firebombed the White House grounds
that's true they they set fire to a
guard Tower and they set fire to St
John's Church this is the historical
church the founding fathers would go to
it was so severe that the president was
forced into his emergency B bunker thus
disrupting His official duties and
really yes wow and my question is why
where was our commission where where was
the uh I mean the photos of that day
when uh you know I go to family
gatherings over the holidays and I show
a photo of an aerial shot of DC which
many of you may have seen smoke rising
out all around the White House in the
surrounding areas from fires that were
being lit the president was forced into
an emergency bunker against his will and
the media made fun of him and called
bunker boy for having had to experience
this Donald Trump said I I went down
they they showed me he clearly didn't
want to be there when law enforcement
then cleared out the extremists who had
laid Siege to the White House I'm being
purposefully hyperbolic you understand
why Donald Trump came out the next day
and took a picture and they attacked him
and insulted him for having defended the
White House and a church that was set on
fire by extreme an extremist faction a
faction so extreme in fact that similar
groups and and cells within the same
ideology had seized several blocks in
various cities in Atlanta in Seattle in
their their Capitol Hill occupation and
in Minnesota with George Floyd Square
yeah videos emerged out of I believe it
was Seattle of armed groups walking
around with AR-15s pointing them at
drivers people of a similar or same
ideology in fact many of these people do
coordinate yep engaged in Insurrection
now of course we can calm down and say a
bunch of extremist activists riding in
the streets no Insurrection oh Fair
Point that neither was the capital well
what about br havav does anybody aive
for the BR Cavanaugh hearings do you
remember them storming in going into
Senators offices I mean I'm telling you
DC was insane and nobody cared until
January 6th happened this was like a
routine thing that was happening to get
their ideas across they were doing
Sittin they were walking in you know in
the Halls Uninvited they couldn't get
these people out I mean it it's just
crazy to think that suddenly they
focused on January 6th and it's hard to
imagine that the feds were not in on it
when we know we have all of these pieces
of footage
at the very least one one thing because
I think there's two strands here both
are interest there's I think there's two
different points and both are
interesting but I think it's important
not to Mi them up because it might risk
us missing the real plot here which is
one is did we have we applied the
different standard of rule of law
throughout this country over the course
of 2020 absolutely we did antifa BLM you
name it if you have a leftwing ideology
it was a mostly peaceful protest you
ignore it that's that's a glaring point
and deserves to be
called out and I think that there can be
no justice with two standards of the
rule of law based on your political
ideology I think to be clear what
happened on January 6th was not some
small joke this was significant in terms
of the number of people terms of you
mean some of the video photos the
mainstream media picked out but I think
what's significant about it is we don't
know what actually caused those people
to act the way they they did was it
really the government instigating
something that otherwise didn't exist
using it as a deflection to achieve a
national security States Revival that
had otherwise receded over the course of
20 years since the post 911 period And
so maybe I've just told you what I
actually think is going on here but
that's what I think the facts suggest is
there was a reason to for these people
to not only get Donald Trump out of
office but to discredit this to relegate
this line of thinking the movement
behind him to the dust bins of history
and this was the way to do it so I think
that there was a lot of depth to this
and it wasn't just that okay well like
this was I mean these are two different
standards two different bad things yes
but this was I think a very serious
forethought exercise in accomplishing
something and unless we see through it
first step when you see a problem is to
name it unless we do that they are going
to accomplish what they set out to
accomplish that's what I believe thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at
timcast.net
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time